I don't I don't think it's the majority
of women but I think there's a large
minority yeah that like a substantial
minority of women that are delusional
yeah I mean there's a large minor
there's a large amount of just General
delusional people I just feel like this
is not yeah that video and that video
and that TV show that is specifically
for those videos no that's just videos
that you've seen and I don't think it
represents so yeah
because I don't I don't see men calling
into shows and demanding Victoria's
Secret models like I just don't see it I
see women demanding six-figure guys tall
guys whatever but I don't see girls or
guys calling into shows and saying I
need a model yeah you just get laughed
at he just is like yeah she's okay not
fat wait that's enough no kids